we now note some elementary properties
of expectations these will be some
properties that are extremely natural
and intuitive but even so they're worth
recording the first property is the
following if you have a random variable
which is non-negative then its expected
value is also non-negative what does it
mean that the random variable is
non-negative what it means is that for
all possible outcomes of the experiment
no matter what the outcome is the
Associated numerical value of the random
variable is a non-negative number what's
the implication of this when we
calculate an expectation we're adding
over all the possible numerical values
of the random variable all the possible
numerical values of the random variable
under this assumption are non-negative
probabilities are also non-negative so
we have a sum of non-negative entries
and therefore the expected value is also
going to be non-negative the next
property is a generalization of this
consider now a random variable that has
the property that no matter what the
outcome of the experiment is the value
of this random variable lies in the
range between two constants a and B in
this case we argue as follows the
expected value by definition is a sum
over all possible values of the random
variable of certain terms now the
possible numerical values of the random
variable are all of them at least as
large as a so this gives us an
inequality of this type then we pull a
factor of a outside the summation and
finally we recall that the sum of a PMF
over all possible values of little X is
equal to 1 why is that the case well
these are the probabilities for the
different numerical values of the random
variable the sum of the probabilities of
all the possible numerical values has to
be equal to 1 because that exhausts all
the possibilities so we obtain a times 1
which is a so what we have proved is
that the expected value is at least as
large as a you can use a symmetrical
argument where the inequalities will go
the opposite way and where s will be
replaced by B's to prove the second
inequality as well the last fact we want
to take note of is the following if we
have a constant and we take its expected
value we obtain the same constant what
does that mean
we have only been talking about expected
values of random variables what does it
mean to take the expected value of a
constant well as we discussed earlier we
can think of a constant as being a
random variable of a very special type a
random variable whose PMF takes this
form this random variable can take only
a single value and the probability of
that single value is equal to 1 this
means that in the formula for the
expected value there's going to be only
one term in this summation and that term
is going to be C times the probability
that our random variable takes the value
C now the product probability is equal
to 1 and we're left with C so this
equality makes sense of course as long
as you understand that a constant can
also be viewed as a random variable of a
very degenerate type now intuitively of
course it's certainly clear what this is
saying that if a certain quantity is
always equal to C then on the average it
will also be equal to C